donald trump so wie jetzt gerade agiert
weil er in vier jahren vielleicht wieder
antreten möchte gibt es eine andere
strategie dahinter vielleicht wegen
seiner geschäftlichen aktivitäten was
glauben sie denn warum ist da denn so
wie er ist er agiert so weil er verloren
hat und er kann das nicht für sich
verkraften das ist das schlimmste was
ihm hätte zu stoßen können wir müssen
uns immer wieder daran erinnern das ist
nicht nur hier
es war keine wahnsinnige niederlage 6
millionen stimmen die ihm gefehlt haben
vielleicht das stimmengewicht noch
zugunsten von dubai aus waren aber er
hat das getan was er tun musste weil er
angst hat will nicht als looser als
verlierer dargestellt werden das problem
beginnt wenn wir dann sehen wie die
menschen ihm gegenüber treten
das so weit von sich wegzuschieben
und dann sieht man aber dass mit der
zeit immer weiter chaos entsteht auch
die spaltung immer tiefer wird und immer
größer wird und wir brauchten doch diese
wahl um wieder zusammenzufinden und
zusammengeführt zu werden und jetzt
sehen wir dass es immer schlechter wird
und je länger das so weitergeht sagte
helfrich gibt es doch noch einen weg für
mich an der macht zu kleben hängen zu
bleiben hier und es gibt natürlich ganz
viele andere die vielleicht ihn
unterstützen dadurch dass sie jetzt im
recht geben dass man vielleicht vor
gericht gehen kann und dass er immer
noch die hoffnung hat dass man doch
vielleicht das wahlergebnis verändern
kann das macht alles viel schlimmer und
das ist die situation der wir jetzt
gegenüber stehen mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren